and I think just again putting yourself
in the in the shoes of of who you're
trying whatever product you have who
you're trying to Market to what is it
that they're what are their likes what
are their dislikes what is it that
you're where's the connection point you
know I've always felt like you can't
wait for people to come to you you have
to go to them so where do they go where
are the where are the places that the
demographic that you're attracting to
we're trying to attract to where do they
go are they gamers are they movie
Watchers do they like cars you know what
is it where do they where are the fan
groups what are the things that they
like that they they spend their time and
that's how you can kind of start to
message to them in a variety of
different ways welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures Jay Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
hello and welcome to 20 minute leaders
today we're going to dive into the world
of streaming meet Jed korenthal the
chief marketing officer at Phoenix a
company that focuses on broadcasting
real-time video streaming for sporting
gaming and other entertainment events as
the chief marketing officer at Phoenix
Jed is in charge of overseeing all
marketing and Business Development
efforts to ensure that companies in
sports and entertainment to grow Their
audience Phoenix has perfected a unique
real-time streaming technology
infrastructure that provides content to
broadcast sized audiences with the
latency of less than half a second he
has Decades of experience leading
marketing business development PR
technology and other Revenue generating
positions across a number of Industries
Nike UPS the unfl Sony and Disney are
only a few of the many clients Judds had
over the years
Jed current fall welcome to 20 minute
leaders I'm so excited to dive into your
world in these next 20 minutes how are
you
I'm well Michael nice to be here
appreciate it it's great to have you
here and Jen you're you know looking
over at the the things you've done there
doing marketing it's all the really the
most exciting uh parts of where
marketing people would be excited about
I mean not just just that's awesome and
I'm really excited to to hear about your
journey within Sony for almost 12 years
director marketing and then obviously
the NFL and you know the list goes on we
already the audience so and today
obviously it's Chief marketing officer
of Cenex and so a lot of a lot to unfold
here and I'll ask exactly as I I usually
like to ask you know connect the dots
for me looking back you know if you're
looking at sort of your career your
trajectory what sort of LED you on this
path what what what how do you how would
you describe it
yeah no it it's been quite a path
actually quite the journey
um I I think for me it's always been you
know I've always tried to look at you
know the newest trends and the latest
things about you know what's happening
from a marketing perspective and how
people are looking at um at marketing
and and from different perspectives so
um you know I was as you mentioned I I
kind of have had sort of two careers if
you will the first half has kind of been
on more on the corporate side where I
spent a long time at Sony I'm a musician
by trade so
um play the drum since I'm seven years
old and
um so I've always had a love for music
and um you know loved working in the
music industry for a while at Sony
um and and from there I created a
cross-platform group
um that allowed us to work across
different Sony business units
um mostly with companies in this Sports
World and that was sort of on purpose a
goal and from that uh it led to my uh
being uh working moving over to the NFL
to help run integrated marketing and
marketing for the league which I did for
about three and a half years and
um it was a lot of fun you know people I
used to have a lot of good cocktail
party jobs you know like music industry
in the NFL and all these fun places
um um you know but over the past
probably 15 plus years I've been more on
the entrepreneurial side and I've you
know started a couple of companies I I
was able to to sell one with my partner
and have been at Phoenix for about the
past six years which is you know a
startup sort of I say more than a sub
I'd say an early stage company but
um very different from working at you
know big company like Sony that's for
sure okay so I I want us to spend a
couple of minutes understanding your
experience with within Sony and the NFL
let's start with the NSL well what was
that experience like when doing
marketing within the NFL that must have
been crazy
I was a little crazy it was great it was
it was great I loved working there
um you know you're it's always nice to
work
um in a field or an industry or a
company that that you know that is
essentially selling a product that you
love
um which is football and and Sports in
general I'm a huge sports fan so
um being able to be close to football
and and Market the game and
um was certainly a lot of fun but you
know it's challenged like every job but
you still have to work hard and you got
to put in the time and
um you know but but I did enjoy it and
and met a lot of great people
um worked in a variety of different
roles within there in terms of working
with like the community
um community relations people I worked
on
um sponsorships and marketing so yeah it
was it was it was a lot of fun
so as you're looking at the different
marketing roles and soon we'll get to
what you're doing today with Phoenix but
I can already tell that you know it
feels like you took on a a variety of
different positions within marketing
right you were doing different things
and and different tasks
and so one of the things that I'd love
to sort of unpack with you is how those
experience come how those experiences
come together to a more holistic view of
marketing for you but so so we'll keep
that in mind but take me for a second to
what you're doing today with then FedEx
with broadcasting uh with very low
latency similar worlds and then we'll
back into higher level stuff yeah you're
right I mean I I I'm sort of someone who
always looks for more so I think yeah
um but yeah so Phoenix is a really
interesting company
um it was developed uh started about
eight or nine years ago uh by a guy who
came over from Switzerland on a
scholarship from Siemens to study
streaming
um which sounds like nothing today but
this was over 20 years ago and you know
streaming was sort of in its infancy so
he was quite the Visionary and is quite
the Visionary
um and built this platform that we Now
operate on and it's it's just amazing
that we're able to stream video
um around the world with less than half
a second of delay or latency so
um you know you and I are using a
technology that allows us to video chat
in real time imagine if you and I were
talking to a hundred million people or
10 million people at the same time and
that's essentially what our technology
does we can stream a sporting event to
the masses while all while everybody is
watching it at the same time in real
time so it's as though you're all at the
stadium or at the racetrack or Marina or
whatever you know the pitch or whatever
your sport of choice is but
um we've kind of eliminated that some of
the the issues that have been plaguing
streaming for some time
so let's talk about those missions for a
second you know streaming has been
around sporting events have been around
longer than you know Supreme sporting
events have been longer around than I
ever been where are where have been the
bottlenecks over the years and how you
know and then I'd love to myself from a
marketer how do you position the
differentiation of the different
companies in this field
sure
um so yeah you're right streaming's been
around for over 20 years streaming
content and um you know most of the
companies that stream uh content today
use a certain form of technology and you
know all the broadcasters and Facebook
and YouTube and you know most of the
companies that people know of that from
where they stream
um are using the same kind of technology
and although it was designed to stream
to a large audience
excuse me it does have some you know
innate problems and the biggest one is
is latency or delay in the Stream so
um it's as though you know I'm sure
people in the audience have experienced
this where you watch a game and then you
get a text or a tweet or you hear
something from your neighbor about a
goal that was scored or a play that
happen and you haven't you know you
haven't yet seen it so that kind of
delay of of watching is is what most of
uh of us have experienced in the
traditional streaming landscape but our
technology uses a newer protocol and
what we've done is we've kind of added
some proprietary technology to it so
we're able to stream that same sporting
event if you will
um with little to no latency so
everybody is watching at the same time
and there's no delay between users and
there's no delay between the field of
play and your device so
um it's it's complicated it's technical
um but you know we have an extremely
smart and and active uh team that has
built and supports this technology to
its fullest and so from a marketing
perspective
how do you you know who are the
different stakeholders that you would
need to Market to and how does that
impact sort of the messaging and the
strategy that you employ here sure yeah
sure
um so we have a lot of different types
of stakeholders that we can essentially
license our technology to it could be
broadcasters it could be Sports
properties you know rights holders
leagues it could be betting companies
betting in the US has become very
popular that's an area that we do a lot
of work in
um so yeah I mean there's any number of
people that own content are the people
that we want to talk to and and your
point about the messaging is a good one
because one of the first campaigns that
that we launched was to try and help
people differentiate between you know
real time and live and so we came up
with the tagline real time and live are
not the same and so you know what we did
was show show the different senses
between the two and allow people to
actually see that although you hear the
term live it's not really live there
there is a delay in that in that stream
um only if it if it's in real time is
the stream eliminated so
um so we said so we've created things
like live in real time and not the same
and you know connecting the world in
real time things of that nature were
part of our messaging at the time right
okay I love that so now let's connect to
dots as to the different things that
you've done from the marketing
perspective let's talk about the role of
a marketer from your from your lenses
you know I have the privilege of asking
you this because you've had such a long
and interesting career in different uh
you know amazing organizations who
really take marketing to the next level
the role of a marketer in its most basic
forms for you now that you've had a lot
of these experiences how do you think to
it
yeah I think it's I think it encompasses
a couple things I think it's it's it's
very much a support
um mechanism I mean for the company it's
a way to message what the company is
trying to do whether it be a product or
a service or technology for that matter
um the idea of of of sort of showcasing
what you do it's the it's kind of the
why the what and the how you know why
you do what we're doing uh what we do
and then how do we do it so you know
those that that format is is what I
think is essential for any marketer and
how you promote whatever it is you know
that your whatever cup you know whatever
your company does if it's a tangible
product or a service or technology you
have to kind of find out that sort of
why you do what you do what you're doing
and then how do you do it and those are
sort of the the kind of what I live by
and I think it's essential for any
marketer really
right I like that and then so as you're
thinking about different strategies or
taking a problem whether it be NFL Sony
or what do you think today with
broadcasting what is the process that
you go through to sort of understand how
to how to best Market it whether it be
from a narrative perspective from a
stakeholder perspective what are
different things that you found to be
most helpful for you
I think one of the things that I've
always tried to do is put myself in the
shoes of the other of the people that
we're marketing to right you know the
person the other side the other the
other end of the table if you will I
mean what is it what is it that I want
that person to see and learn and what
kind of reaction do I want them to have
to what we're doing and how we're
marketing to them about what it is that
we're selling pitching offering exactly
you know Etc so I think that's important
to put yourself in the shoes of of the
person that you're marketing to so you
can understand what it is that they're
going to gain from what you you know
what you have and and you know the other
thing that that I think is kind of a bit
of a lost art is is listening I think
too many people like to talk and hear
their own voice a little bit too much
um I think it's really important to
listen to the people that you're you're
meeting with listen to what they're
saying what they're not saying try and
read the room you know really understand
what the objectives are
um of of the company and what you're
trying to achieve and then take that
information and then come up with the
right plan
but how do you actually go about and and
check that you've successfully put
yourself in those shoes because that is
something that you know as a in
kindergarten I was told that that's why
I should aim to do and since then I've
been figuring out really what's the
right what's the right way to do that so
how do you how do you even go about
fathering this
well I mean you know so
imagine you know what what your product
is and who you who would you want to buy
that product ultimately right I mean
we're all selling something whatever
that is even a doctor is selling
somebody selling his services so you
know so who is the person that you want
to buy your services is it geared more
towards a female audience is it geared
more towards a male audience is it is it
older is it younger you know what is it
what you're trying to achieve from there
it sounds good so I think that at this
point one of the things that I've been
told from a very young age was you know
to put myself in other people's shoes to
to create empathy so that I can then
understand what you know how to pres you
know how to how to you know message and
present things in a way that it would be
um both suitable for their needs and
something that they could be they could
relate to how do you do that effectively
as a marketing leader how do you
effectively create that skill set so
that you can be a good marketer and and
develop that empathy
well it doesn't take you know it doesn't
take a day it takes a little time
um I will say that but uh but I think it
you know I think as there's a number of
different things in the eyes I mentioned
listening before is is one skill or or
it's a lost art
um and just you know I'm a voracious
reader I read just a ton of stuff
do a lot of research and you know
anytime I'm talking with somebody or
meeting with somebody
you know I try and find out as much
about them their company uh as humanly
possible
you know again things that may seem
obvious aren't so obvious to everybody
but
um and I think just again putting
yourself in the in the shoes of of who
you're trying whatever product you have
who you're trying to Market to what is
it that they're what are their likes
what are their dislikes what is it that
you're where's the connection point you
know I've always felt like you can't
wait for people to come to you you have
to go to them so where do they go where
are the where are the places that the
demographic that you're attracting to
we're trying to attract to where do they
go are they gamers are they movie
Watchers do they like cars you know what
is it where do they where are the fan
groups what are the things that they
like that they they spend their time and
that's how you can kind of start to
message to them in a variety of
different ways you know coke coke puts
their message out in 50 different
channels and not because they think that
that you know you're going to see a a
Coke billboard and say oh I've got to
run to the store and get a Coke but it
becomes almost subconscious that when
you walk into a deli or something and
you're thirsty you get a Coke because
you've seen it so many times and that's
you know it it's sort of that that that
Mantra of trying to reach people in a
variety of ways in a variety of channels
in the places that they're interested in
what do you get most excited by you know
work in your process well what really
affects you most
I I you know I love it when
um when we do something and people
respond to it we had a
um I'm trying to think of who it was but
we did
we we did sort of a targeted
um email and newsletter blast to a bunch
of people but we did it in such a way
that it was it was the way we worded it
was very specific and what was what was
so fascinating to me is that we had
gotten someone from a company that we
had been trying to reach and were having
trouble reaching someone from that
company actually reached out to us and
said you know I saw what you're doing
this is this really makes a lot of sense
I I'd very much like to talk to you
about what you're doing so you know when
you get you know when you get that kind
of Engagement when you get that kind of
response it's just like it just makes
everything that you're doing worthwhile
I love it Jed I really want to thank you
for for coming on and uh for sharing
these 20 minutes with me and it sounds
like you've had quite quite a few
experiences that that were both very
very positive and really it sounds like
fundamentally they can't understanding
you know you know how they
you know understand where you know the
other side is what is the right
messaging for them being able to be
adaptive to the different needs and the
different circumstances of what you're
offering and that versatility with
empathy is at the end what makes for a
good marketer so again thank you for for
this time and this energy and then I
look forward to sharing this with the
world
excellent Michael great to speak with
you
thank you